[MUSIC]
On a recent episode of Grit and Growth,
we explored the reality of raising capital
where none has been raised before,
with Indian entrepreneur Aditi Srivastava,
CEO and co-founder of Pocket Aces.
Entrepreneurship in India is
flourishing as today's guests,
Sandeep Singhal knows well.
>> We have seen returning entrepreneurs,
the next generation of talent is coming
out and starting their own companies.
So whether it's a Flipkart, whether it's
a Snapdeal, whether it's all of these
companies are now throwing off talent
who are going and doing the next thing.
>> Sandeep is the managing director of
Mumbai based Nexus Venture Partners.
He's an expert in venture capital in
India and has invaluable advice for
ambitious entrepreneurs.
>> That individual when they're presenting
to me should get me as excited about
the problem as they are.
Because that's what they
are going to do day in, day out.
It's not sales, but it's motivation,
it's getting that trust built in the other
person that hey, I can make this happen.
[MUSIC]
>> I'm Doris Teeter, and
this is a masterclass by Grit & Growth
with Stanford Graduate School of Business.
The show where Africa and
South Asia's intrepid entrepreneurs
share their trials and triumphs.
Today, Sandeep Singhal
shares his knowledge and
experience in the world
of venture capital.
We hear about what sets the Indian
investment landscape apart,
how Sandeep decides which markets and
ideas to invest in, and
the single most important characteristic
he looks for in an entrepreneur.
[MUSIC]
So without further ado,
over to you, Sandeep.
>> So I went to Stanford,
graduated in 1987, worked for
a startup in the Bay Area
that was funded by a VC.
So I got an opportunity to actually
see how a VC funded startup works.
That company was eventually acquired
by Digital Equipment Corporation.
So I actually saw the whole journey from
the time that the company was started
to the time it was exited.
It wasn't a great exit for
the investors, but
it was an interesting
product that was built.
Subsequently, I went to business
school and joined McKinsey.
And while I was at McKinsey, I came and
spent some time in India in 1997.
And at that time,
there wasn't really any real VC in India.
There weren't any early stage investors,
and
so there wasn't really this
capital available at that time.
I saw that gap, went back to the US,
pretty much clear in my mind that I
wanted to do something in that space.
Ended up partnering with
a fellow McKinsey partner and
we started eVentures, and
that was set up as an incubator.
And so from our perspective,
it was a player on two areas.
One was looking at
the Internet economy and
seeing how we could bring global
models to the Indian market.
And the second focus area was
looking at global services,
Indian companies that will provide
services to global clients.
>> You're the managing director
of Nexus Venture Partners.
Can you tell me a little bit about
the firm and its investment thesis?
>> So the fund itself is
based out of the Bay Area, so
we have an office in Menlo Park and
we have offices in India.
So we have office in Mumbai, which is
where I'm based, and office in Bangalore.
We had two clear areas of
investment that we felt
were opportunities in a cross border fund.
The two areas that we identified,
one was cross border technology companies.
So these are companies that
are starting in India,
but have a global customer in mind.
The second area where we felt there
was an opportunity was the domestic
consumption play.
India started seeing significant growth
on domestic consumption in the 2003,
2004 timeframe, and we felt that
that consumption would move more and
more towards digital platforms.
[MUSIC]
>> What would you say has been the biggest
improvement in the startup landscape
from an investment capital race
standpoint over this past 15 years?
Is it just that deepening of experience,
more opportunity brought more talent
into the early stage funding space?
>> Absolutely, the first thing was
that you had role models emerge.
So we funded MakeMyTrip in
the original 2000 timeframe.
By 2006, 2007,
MakeMyTrip was a reasonably large company,
they had a business
model that was scaling.
They had initially started with the cross
border play between bringing Indians
back to India from the US and
other markets.
But by the time, 2006, 2007, they actually
had a domestic market play as well.
So, one was, somebody could look at
what Deep Kalra had built at MakeMyTrip,
and say I can build something similar.
Maybe in a different area, but
I can build something similar.
So they were in some ways,
rule books that were available for
founders to base their businesses on.
Second, capital, whether it was us,
a couple of other funds got started
the same time, capital became available.
And third, big shift that happened was
that talent started coming to startups.
In the earlier days, the best
talent would go to large companies.
So you had the Unilever, the McKinseys
of the world, getting the best talent.
But by 2006, 2007, if you had a funded
startup, you could potentially get
some of the best talent from the business
schools, or from the IITs, and so on.
The other thing that has happened is
we have seen returning entrepreneurs.
The companies that started in 2006
onwards, I think because they
have only seen growth from then on,
they've never seen a real downturn.
The next generation of the talent in
those companies is coming out and
starting their own companies.
So whether it's a Flipkart,
whether it's a Snapdeal,
whether it's Byju's, all of these
companies are now throwing out talent,
who are going and doing the next thing.
[MUSIC]
>> How is the India investing environment
different from Silicon Valley today,
or is it?
>> So the Valley is still
a lot more vibrant in terms
of the idea exchange,
in terms of talent availability.
There's just a lot more depth in terms of
advisors, people who have sort of gone
through the journey, maybe not even once,
they've gone twice or thrice.
And people have actually
adapted in the Valley.
And in India, it's still early from that
perspective, we are 30, 40 years behind.
The other big sub difference in
some ways is India as a market
has only started evolving
towards a convenience-led
approach in more recent times,
>> Well,
what does the convenience-led
approach mean?
>> India has been primarily value-based or
discount-based market.
So most of the companies that
have gotten created in India have
used discounting and
price as a primary means of competition.
Now, when you do that, one of the big
drivers obviously is the need for capital.
That is changing, partly I think
COVID has had a role to play, but
the other thing is There is now more and
more shift towards the consumer
looking for convenience.
And whether it is Zomato or
Swiggy on food delivery,
whether it is an academy on education,
people are willing to pay.
And they're willing to pay full price or a
good price, let's say, not full price, but
a good price for
the services that they're getting.
And that makes the unit
economics more attractive.
It allows companies to scale without
it taking up as much capital.
And it allows founders to
compete based on product and
experience, and not just based on price.
That in my mind is a big
shift that's happened.
[MUSIC]
>> Let's go into some of the basics
of early stage investment.
And I'm thinking here about some of
the inefficiencies in the pre-seed and
early stage investment ecosystem.
Is there enough capital,
enough high net worth individuals,
enough angel investors out there for
entrepreneurs to find?
>> There are enough executives
from large Internet companies,
there are enough high net
worth individuals, family,
officers that are now doing
angel investments in startups.
>> So, if you have a good idea,
and a good growth story,
you should be able to find an audience.
>> Today, yes, and interestingly,
this cohort of Y Combinator had,
I think,
40% of the companies are from India.
That's the other shift
that's happening is,
early stage capital is not just
available from Indian angels.
But Indian companies are now
being looked at globally.
You have all the accelerators on
the globe now in present in India,
TechStars is here,
Y Combinator is here, Angellist is here.
The availability to raise capital from
a global pool is also increasing.
>> Okay, I want to switch gears now, and
I want to play a little game
of investing true or false.
And so, I'm going to ask you to say true
or false, and then to provide sort of
a one or two sentence explanation
of why you answer true or false.
So, the first question is, angel or
venture investors will want their
money back in five to seven years.
True, the rationale behind that
is we are working with a finite
amount of capital and
that capital has to be returned, so
that it can be re-utilized for
the next stage of innovation.
And if a company hasn't scaled enough
in five to seven years, and typically,
that would mean that they'll find
it hard to scale from there on.
>> The expectation for
return on capital is different for
emerging market angel investors than for
Silicon Valley angel investors.
>> False, I think angel investors
globally are looking for high returns.
And today, Indian investors
are able to go on to AngelList and
invest in value-based companies,
and vice versa.
So, everybody's looking for
the best company and the best return.
>> So, there's no artificial geographic
friction anymore in the system,
capital will go where it wants to go?
>> From a returns perspective, yes,
everybody, they want equally high returns.
>> Next question, founders will see 20%
ownership in each investment round?
>> Mostly true, there are companies where,
because of early
market leadership,
the founder is able to dictate terms and
reduce the dilution that they
see in each subsequent drought.
In most cases, you will see a 20%
dilution between pro rata rights and
ownership for the new investor coming in.
>> But I understand from talking to
a DT at Pocket Aces that sometimes,
investors will have a de facto board seat,
but they won't want to take on
the statutory liabilities of becoming
an official member of the board.
Is that a common practice?
>> In India, particularly the global firms
follow that more than the Indian firms.
>> Okay, so next true false question.
Lead investors will always ask for
a board seat?
>> True, I have yet to see round getting
done where the lead investor did
not ask for a board seat,
so, I would say it's true.
>> Okay, next question.
Founders will not hold a majority
stake in their business post series A?
>> False,
you would have to have been very,
very diluted at the seed level
to have reached that position.
So, the only time when we see that
is when companies struggle to
scale at the seed level.
Founders can overestimate latent demand,
and
they end up struggling more to get to
a point where they are ready for series A,
that does sometimes lead
to higher dilution of seed.
If that happens, it's a tough situation
for everyone, the founders and
angels included.
Because typically,
a seasoned investor does not like to be in
a company where both citizen,
the founders are below majority.
>> The board will have the ability to
replace the CEO in later stages based on
that person's performance.
>> True, the board does retain
the right to change the CEO.
However, the founder has a lot of
operating control over the business.
So, if they are doing a terrific job, the
board will hardly ever replace a founder.
The idea is to have the founders
scale alongside the company.
And to do that, you have to think
forward along with the founder.
And either it is helping them find
the right people to work with them,
to cover for the areas where
they may not be experienced, or
the founder themselves,
then pick up skills.
[MUSIC]
>> One of the things we learned
from a DT at Pocket Aces was that,
having multiple institutions in
a funding round meant that she looked to
different investors for
different advice and support.
In some of the deals that you've done
where you're side by side with somebody
else, how do you work out who's involved
with what aspects of advising the founder?
Is that all happening at the board level,
or where else is it happening?
>> So, it starts with
the founder themselves, right?
And this is not just a firm issue, it's
actually the board member issue, right?
One of the things that good firms do is,
even though you have one board
member who's representing
the firm on the company's board,
you're making yourself available
as a firm to the founder.
So, that's one thing that at Nexus, we
look at, that a founder should be able to
talk to any one of us, even though
that person is not on the board.
As a board, particularly on major issues,
I think it is very important
to coordinate, and we do that both within
the board, we also do it within the firm.
We have conversations
around our companies,
we get feedback from other partners
saying, hey, have you thought about this,
or have you thought about that?
Sometimes, depending on how you're
thinking about the problem,
you'll say maybe you should go talk to
my colleague on this particular issue,
because they have dealt
with it in another company.
And they may be able to give
you experience-based advice,
rather than I give you theoretical advice.
[MUSIC]
So l want to get a little bit
into this whole question of,
how do you get to know an entrepreneur?
What characteristics are you looking for?
When somebody walks in the door,
what do you need to know about them?
>> Number one is energy level.
You can tell from a person in
the way that they interact with you,
what their energy levels are, and
how will they sustain their energy
as they build out the business.
>> Define energy.
>> It comes from passion.
It comes from internal drive, but
it's also about how you are seeing
the desire to build a business.
And good entrepreneurs just want
to build something big, right?
You're not coming and say,
I just want to solve a problem.
There are many people that
want to solve problems.
But these are people who are saying,
I want to solve a problem at scale.
I want to solve a problem
with a group of people.
I want to build,
I want to have people around me that are
equally passionate about building things.
That energy, that passion sort
of is the starting point.
>> So they're not just a lone wolf.
And they don't just have a compelling
problem they want to solve.
They have a growth vision, and they at
least have some people who are with them.
>> That's great.
>> And so you're not looking at
the numbers at all at first, or have you
already done a bunch of due diligence
before they even get in the front door?
>> From a seed and series A perspective,
it is less about numbers and
it's more about people.
Numbers really start coming into
account in series B and series C.
But at a seed and series A,
very few companies will have
numbers that you can depend on for
making a decision on a long term basis
>> Right, I mean,
they'll put something in front of you,
but you both know that it's vapor.
>> What we do look for is size of market.
So for us it's very important that you're
planning to target a large market.
And the reason why I say planning versus
saying you're targeting a large market is
because there is a third part of this,
which is focus.
So you're passionate about solving a
problem, you know that you're going after
a large market, but
you're doing it in a very focused way.
So sometimes what ends up happening is,
the focus can make it appear
that the market is small because
you've defined an issue.
You're going after the top 100,000
customers that really need audio books,
right?
And it may appear like a small market, but
you can walk me through and say okay, if I
get these 100,000, that I can get the next
million, and then I can get the 5 million.
So that's the third thing is focus, and
many entrepreneurs struggle with that.
That ability to walk me through
why what you're doing right now,
will allow you the right to get
to the next set of customers.
How will you be able to take the learnings
from your 3 billion in revenue and
scale up to 10, 20, 50, right?
This is my growth horizon
to get to this point, and
then I'm going to go on to the next
growth horizon and the next one, right?
And an entrepreneur that's thinking
that way is also very well
aligned from an investor perspective
because that's how investments work.
You start by saying, okay, my first thing
is, I need to get to product market fit.
The next thing is,
I need to get to a GTM fit.
I need to be able to have a go to
market model which is repeatable,
which is scalable.
The next thing is, I'm now going
to be able to protect my moat,
whatever I've created as a moat, right?
So at each stage, you are thinking
through what is the nature of
problem you're solving in your business.
That a good entrepreneur is
able to sort of outline that.
Third is or the fourth thing
is the ability to motivate.
That individual when they're presenting
to me, should get me as excited about
the problem as they are because that's
what they are going to do day in, day out.
Once they have the company and
they're out in the market, they're going
to be trying to convince customers.
They're going to try and
convince the best talent and employees.
They will be trying to convince the best
partners to work with them, right?
So they have to get me convinced.
It's not sales, but
it's motivation, right?
It's getting that trust built in the other
person that, hey, I can make this happen.
And the final thing is
the ability to listen and adapt.
What you need to be able to, and
this is what we test in the conversation,
is will throw them a curveball.
We will ask a question which would get
you upset or which will sort of say, hey,
this just can't work, right?
And we see how the person reacts.
Do they get upset?
Or others are thinking,
why is this guy telling me this?
What do I need to do differently?
You can tell that this person's
wheels are turning in their head and
they're thinking about the problem.
They're thinking, so that ability
to listen because the market is
always telling you something,
the competitors are telling you something.
>> So
you want them to have the passion and
the persuasive power of an evangelist,
but one who also listens?
>> Yes, because if you don't listen,
then you're stubborn.
And the risk of being stubborn is,
you can hit your head on the wall and
never be able to get it across it.
>> So another way I would think about this
is, you want someone who's in love with
the problem they're trying to solve,
not with their specific solution.
>> That is a good way to put it.
[MUSIC]
>> Okay, now I'm going to
put you in the other chair.
I want you to go back to your
days of founding businesses and
working in startups.
You're in a conversation with
a potential first round HOR seat,
let's not say seat,
let's say seed or series A investor.
How should you be assessing this
investor as a potential partner?
>> Again, the starting point is this
investor passionate about this problem?
Maybe not as much as I am, but
at least has enough passion and
is thinking about this,
not just from a standpoint of, okay,
I'll bet behind Sandeep and
he'll make me money.
So this is a person who has thought about
this problem, has a point of view on it,
and is therefore able to ask
me intelligent questions.
>> So, they shouldn't be looking for
someone who just says,
you convinced me here, but let's do it.
You actually ought to go past that because
I think a lot of entrepreneurs would be so
excited.
If that was the initial response, they
would feel like they just hit a home run.
>> I would at least ask the person
what about what I said convinced you?
In a nice way, is there anything
that I should be doing differently?
Is there anything that, what is it
that you think I should do more of?
At least check that this person
is not a so lazy check writer,
but is actually going to be a partner
with you through the journey.
>> Because you want more than the check.
>> Yes, because see,
any startup is not a straight line.
You are going to run into problems that
you hadn't got dissipated at the time of
the fund raise.
If there is an understanding as
to why that investment was made,
you can always go back to that and say,
this is what we were looking to do.
What was wrong with our assumption.
And that ability to do that requires
that there has to be some common set of
assumptions between the entrepreneur and
the investor.
So if you haven't had that
conversation at the start and
let's say Gerry wrote you a check, then
how do you have this conversation later?
>> I want to just ask you a little
bit about the due diligence process.
We talked about valuations don't really
mean much in these early stages,
but is it a point of
contention in the negotiation?
>> In today's world, yes,
valuations have crept up.
There is an expectation from
all founders that they should
get Silicon Valley based valuations.
Not all founders are targeting very
large markets, equally large markets or
have the same Capabilities that some of
the returning founders in the Valley or
even in India might bring.
So what ends up happening
is they read stories in
the press that somebody raise $15 million,
and
sees a round at a 35 pre money valuation.
And they think that, hey, if they can
do that, maybe I'm not as good, but
maybe I'll get a 25 or 35, and the real
clearing price is 10, right, or 8.
There is some level of expectation
management that needs to
happen in even early stage valuations.
>> You've talked with so
many founders and evaluated so
many companies that are raising capital.
What are the most common mistakes
that entrepreneurs make during
those early fundraising stages,
pre-seed and early stage funding?
>> So one of the things I
tell all my founders is
don't go to market stating
valuation expectation.
You can share with the market what your
last round post money was, you can share
with the market how your company has grown
from the last round, but leave it at that.
Have the market tell you what
they think is a fair valuation.
Second is, it is important for
you to have clarity on what
are the risks that you're going to
face going forward in your business.
We see a lot of situations where
entrepreneurs come expecting
everything to be hunky dory all the time,
and it isn't the case.
It means that they're not good listeners,
they're not so seeing,
okay, here's a potential
problem that I could run into.
You should be able to imagine that
once you had the money in your bank,
what would you do with it?
And what are the risks that you would see,
and how you would mitigate those risks.
We have people that come to us for
funding, and
they haven't even understood what
their competitive landscape is.
And that, I think, is just sloppiness.
So those are the kinds of issues
that a founder should have
a few conversations with friendlies.
Obviously, talking to your own existing
investors and using them as a devil's
advocate is very valuable, and
existing investors should do that.
They should not try and
be cheerleaders for the founders.
But in these situations,
they should be very objective and
play the role of external investor.
It's a tricky thing to do because you
don't want to have that person get
upset at you for you saying something,
but it's important that that person hear
it from you before they hear
it from excellent investor.
[MUSIC]
>> I'm just curious, is there
a question that you wish I'd asked you?
What am I missing here?
>> How do you look at various
opportunities that come to you, right?
So today,
I can have an opportunity that's coming in
a company that's building
the next marketplace,
it could be an opportunity in a company
that's building the next education portal.
There's a company that's coming to me,
that has the next content play.
Now as a investor, I have to make choices,
because as a fund,
we are looking to invest across 25 to 27
companies in a fund to create a portfolio.
So I'm looking at either the stage
of the company, I'm looking at
the industry in which they're playing,
so I'm making a overall portfolio.
And so sometimes, I may have too much
of a weightage in a particular area,
in which case,
I may not be able to invest in you,
nothing wrong with the company
that you're running.
Sometimes, you see three great companies
come to you around the same time.
How do you make a choice?
You're basically saying I can only back
one, I only have capacity to do one.
How do I make that choice?
And that's where it's very
important from a founder
perspective to get to the right VC and
have a point of view
as to this fund is more likely
to invest in a contemplate.
This fund or this partner is
more likely to back marketplace.
And try and get as much information about
the individual, not just about the firm.
It's very important that you think
through and look at the partners,
look at what the partners are doing,
look at what their interests are.
What have they spoken about in the last
six months about their areas of interest?
People talk about, hey,
I'm looking at investing in this area,
you need to sort of stay on top of that.
As a founder, I think going in
prepared with an understanding
of how the investor ecosystem
looks like can be very
helpful in an efficient
fundraising process.
>> So
how many deals do you look at a year?
And of those,
how many do you actually invest in?
And then I want to talk a little
bit about the ones who turned away.
>> Normally,
we would do 7 to 8 deals a year.
These are series A investments.
So we will probably do an equal amount,
maybe more as seeds.
So in the course of a year, we'll probably
end up doing about 20 investments or
18 investments out of
which 8 would be series A,
an 8 to 10 would be seed investments.
Our series A investments would
range between, say 3 to 7 million,
and our seed investments would typically
be anywhere between 250k to 1 million.
Sometimes we'll go slightly higher.
We expect that in our seed investments,
maybe a fifth of them or
a quarter of them would make it
to a series A, and others won't.
So these are very fundamental
risks that we're taking.
And to get to this number,
we will probably see
on average 500 to 600 companies a year.
>> So you're saying no an awful lot?
>> Yes, and
what we do is we say no quickly, and
we know we will get things wrong.
For us, a lot has to do with
the founder of the team.
So, sometimes, you can look at a plan and
say, the space doesn't make any sense.
But something about that plan says I
should at least talk to the person.
So we will do a call with the person,
and sometimes you say,
this may not be the right problem
that he or she is solving, but
they are just a great, just amazing team.
So let's go back and look at a seed
investment and see where they go.
[MUSIC]
>> What I find fascinating
about this is the seed round,
the personality of the founder and
the team are so important.
When you're letting them down,
when you're in the room with them and
you're going to say no, in a sense,
it must be hard for them to take.
Because you're saying no to them based
on their personality and who they are.
And do they understand that and
how do they respond?
I mean, I would love to hear
an example of an unsuccessful pitch and
how you handle it, and
how the founder accepted that.
>> Normally, we will let the founder know
that either it is because of the space or
it is because we felt that there was
something in the way that they were
presenting or the way they were
taking the solution forward,
that we weren't comfortable with.
>> It's not your role to
be their psychiatrist.
>> No, but we will say, hey, listen,
we think that you are too focused
on marketing and this needs you to
build a better product first before
we would spend money on marketing.
Or it could be that you need
to build a team around you.
It's an interesting idea, but
we just don't see a team.
Can execute an instinct.
Sometimes that person will say,
thank you for the feedback, goes and
works on it for the next three months and
then comes back.
Others will just say, don't want
to deal with this, let's move on.
>> So, can you share a story of
a time when you didn't invest and
then regretted it later.
>> So, we did not put money into Ola.
Ola is India's equivalent of Uber, right.
So, Ola is the largest
player in the taxi space.
And the reason why we didn't do it is
because when he initially started,
the regulatory framework did not
allow Taxi hailing through an app.
And so, there was a risk of
either director liability or
potentially this thing being
shut down by the government.
And so, we didn't want to take that risk.
We did not invest in fresh works
at this point other than Zoho.
It's India's largest sort of software.
SAS company,
because our view was that they were at
the point that they came to for
investment.
They were effectively a copy of Zendesk.
Interestingly, the initial
growth that happened was because
the Zendesk founder wrote a rad.
And complained about how Fresh desk
just totally copied the Desk and
how they were just trying
to compete on price.
And any customer that was looking for
a helpdesk solution at the time and
felt that Desk was too
expensive went to Fresh desk.
[LAUGH] So, and for
me is as important as right?
You take what you get even if
they're copying something.
That is global.
How will the differentiated and
garish had a clear path of how they
would differentiate themselves?
Visa we Zendesk and they've done that.
>> And that brings us to
the end of today's masterclass.
I want to thank Sandeep Singh for
sharing his insights with us today.
From Sandeep's perspective, early stage
investment decisions are often based less
on the numbers and
more on the people involved.
For entrepreneurs to attract strong
partners, they need to demonstrate real
insight into the competitive
landscape of their market and
to build businesses that
solve problems at scale.
Founders need to have
a strong internal drive.
For Sandeep, what he looks for
an entrepreneur is clear.
>> Number one, his energy level.
That individual when they're presenting
to me should get me as excited about
the problem as they are.
[MUSIC]
>> This has been a masterclass
from Britain growth
with Stanford Graduate School of Business,
and I'm your host, Darrius Teeter.
If you want to find out more about how
Stanford Graduate School of Business
is partnering with entrepreneurs
throughout Africa and South Asia,
visit seed.stanford.edu/podcast.
If you liked this episode don't forget to
hit follow and share it with a friend.
Grit & Growth is a podcast by Stanford
Seed from Stanford Graduate School of
Business.
Laurie Fuller researched and
developed content for
this episode with additional
research by Jeff Crickett.
Kindred Gleditsch is our production
coordinator in our executive producer is
Tiffany Steve's, with writing and
production from Isabel Dillard and
sound design and mixing by
Alex Bennett at Lower Street Media.
Thanks for joining us.
We'll see you next time.
[MUSIC]